his show single parents is in its second
season now on ABC Wednesday nights at
9:30 p.m. Eastern Time and and you saw a
man whom I thought of last night when
the Rams had the game on the foot of
Greg the leg and it did not go through
the uprights one of the biggest diehard
Rams fans I know taran killam good to
see you sir great to see you rich it's
pretty unbelievable you never wanted to
come down to a single play like that and
if it has to be on anybody's shoulders
or leg it's in it's Greg's so you know
great football in that in that it just
just it was so gut-wrenchingly cuz cuz
sunday was that was the bad game like
last night was a great game yeah it was
fun to watch sunday was a mess and like
kind of embarrassing now you were there
right you go to I try to go to every
home game I took my family camping so I
missed the home game so I was literally
on the shores of Lake Mohave with my
phone watching watching the Rams Bucs
game and and just throwing rocks into
the water and so you had reception
oh no yeah yeah yeah AT&T there you go
thank you so much people probably
working buildings right across from us
right now making sure that you can do
they can sense it then yeah whoa
making sure you can do that this little
company just get a boost and taran
killam maybe they did yeah oh my gosh I
mean and and I won't say this yeah girly
does look like the girlie of 20 he had a
20-18 game last night although still
just 15 carries that what it was or its
yeah 15 still it's still an unbalanced
scenario that's going on right there's a
sloppiness because all our TR our
defense has all the weapons but our
secondaries getting beat like what the
Rams have done especially since McVeigh
has become coach is they're bringing in
these mentor spots and I feel like it
started with Whitworth where they bring
seasoned players in to kind of mentor
let me know even Talib who's been
wonderful and great and I love to leave
but you kind to get beat and like Peters
drives me crazy he drives me crazy
because he's like the Hulk
and not in a good way where he needs the
rage of of messing up to then play good
you'll get huge plays out of Marcos but
only after he lets somebody buy him you
know and and that inconsistency I think
I you know eight touchdowns eight
throwing touchdowns against us in the
last two games is evidence of that so so
I think we just kind of we start slow to
that that is every game this season we
start slow and then we come back and
like the resilience of the Rams right
now I think is still impressive and
that's why I haven't given up on them in
this season oh no that here's what he
giving up then yeah they're three and
two yeah okay they do have a big game
against the 49ers showing up through
next week but I mean you look at the
roster there's a ton of talented yes
well and and your coach is still your
coach yeah and Wade Phillips is still
Wade Phillips correct and Cooper Cup is
an emerging bright shining stars amazing
D Nights phrase yeah you know I mean he
is he is true I think he is their best
receiver yeah and he's becoming that and
most halls are sure he's reliable and I
set it off at the top of the show his
route running his precise yes hands are
pristine and he never his awareness of
where he is on the field is spot on yes
and he never makes the wrong first move
it's like as if his first move is always
good for another five yards yes every
time he catch he's so slippery too he
said there's a there's a play you know
he'd caught it for eight yards and and
somebody got his leg and I thought he
was gone and it was a rare instance
where they actually were able to hang on
to Cooper right he's amazing but but
woods and cooks too I feel like I hope
cooks is okay and what a catch that was
that was beautiful wasn't it there and
Goff is amazing I just I wish he would
learn a pump fake you know what I mean
now a pump fake would go a long way with
that guy because he's just he's he's
telegraphing a little too much from from
the little I know I could never do you
know I'm a fan and I think just I think
a head in a pump fake and this would buy
him so much Terron kill him here on the
Rich Eisen show now how did you become a
Rams fan again how did this all start
I'm a Los Angeles native yes for most of
my life we had not had a team I was a
big Raiders fan when they were here
bo Jackson and Marcus Allen how he
longed right and then and then we didn't
have a team and I kind of floated around
it was cool seeing you talked to Richard
Sherman because I was following the
Seahawks right and I was at that Super
Bowl where they threw the interception
at the one-yard line which is
heartbreaking oh my god I thought you
you you were gonna be at the Super Bowl
in New York City because you know at the
kind of dovetails within the seven C's
yeah yes yeah I missed that I think
because whenever I wasn't working I was
flying back to be home cuz Kobe was
still here working right
but the reason I'm a Rams fan is is I
love football my whole life and and more
and more each year and I promised myself
when I was 19 or 20 that the first team
back in my adult life I was gonna start
from the ground up and become a die-hard
and unfortunately it was the ramps and
the Rams have have done just wanders
around really fun um I would it's been a
tough five-day stretch it's all I would
say it's a long marathon here it's been
pretty brutal I was sad to lose in dama
Caen so to see him come back and score
that final touchdown was especially
painful yeah yeah you knew it I could
have fallen down on the ground one more
first down nets and running down the
field oh my gosh so okay let's get into
one of this is one of my favorite
stories of Chris you were at the big
slick was correct yes you notice not at
the were not at the game the softball
game
all right Paul Rudd has told me his
version of this story great so I'd like
to have you started first and at all
it's the big slick is an incredible
event in Kansas City every year they
raised over two million dollars just
this year alone for Children's Mercy
Hospital in Kansas City it is just which
is a heaven on earth for so many
families and so many sick kids and it's
just an amazing event yeah that starts
in essence with a huge celebrity
softball game on the field correct of
Kauffman Stadium for the home of the
yeah City Royals
well even even earlier that day you go
to the hospital you go to Children's
Mercy Hospital which is the best part of
the trip you spend time with the
families you spend time with the
children you see why you're there
exactly and
and it really sets the tone of love and
support and camaraderie and then yeah
you go to royal Stadium and you play you
play a softball game that's fun and
silly but yes Patrick mahomes was there
and Travis Kelce too now both there now
with mahomes we all saw he went yard he
went yard he first of all they bring in
the fence let's be clear about that he
didn't knock it out of the park they
bring in a shorter oh yes under the but
it was basically we're seeing it right
here a deep fly ball to what normally
would be a can of corn in left field but
it was way over the fence and he did a
bat flip and least and that's that's
Hollywood phony bs is what that is
because that is his second time up OK in
a row the the inning before yes he was
the last at-bat two outs and he pops it
up I'm playing shortstop Paul Rudd's
playing third base he pops it up and I
scream Oh God and boom and I catch
Patrick mahomes his pop-up fly and he's
out and there was thank goodness no
reaction no reaction from the crowd
nobody cares I look over at Paul Wright
at third base and I just see the respect
kind of like drop like leave his face
looking at me and he says Wow
I wouldn't have done that and I turned
to Paul I said I had to I'm a Rams fan
and then Koechner runs out on the field
because Koechner is just like court
jester chaos like and he was give me
that ball and I can tell he wants
Patrick to go right again and I say
absolutely not and I keep the ball put
it in my pocket we go up the next inning
they have Patrick go up right away
and he knocks it out of the mini park
and that's oh that's the only footage
they put out from that weekend was
Patrick mo Holmes and I held on to the
ball and I went up to my home's after
the game who is the nicest person in the
world the most charismatic charming
lovely and talented athlete but I went
up to him and he's just you know he's
like in the processional of like so
gracious and saying hi to everybody and
I walk up and I handle the ball and I go
go Rams and he's in auto mode so he's
like oh man thanks
so so I had my moment and I felt very
good about it but it's been a race from
history so I'm really glad that you
aired that here if we can air that pop
off again because I'll tell ya the way
that Paul Rudd told me the story yes is
that mahomes the place was going crazy
then he said yes everybody knows it's a
totally anti climactic he's thinking cuz
he's at third base he's right next to
you yes here's the cheese fan he's
thinking there's no way I'm catching
this ball yes I am NOT gonna catch this
and make Patrick mahoma he's not gonna
record a put out on the otra Mahal
there was no way I was letting that ball
fast this is going through his head he
says you swoop in yes make the catch him
yes you looked at him and you said I'm a
Rams fan I had to he was like I can't
believe you just caught my homes pop-up
I wouldn't have done that I'm a Rams fan
did you call my house my eat in your
house it looks like you waved him off
yes I didn't do you see you kind of see
you see rug kind of like fake smile look
at me and look away he got a gives me no
why do you do that for charity man then
the next inning mahomes hit leadoff yeah
yeah they fudged it they fudged it it's
Hollywood fake I don't think there's
conventional sports it's all it's all
fake there's no appeal play out look at
how shallow that fence is oh yeah I mean
he went way out to the logo to a tee
what's Dane Cook the one who created no
David Cook on Love Field yeah so he was
out twice technically it's just fax fax
you know what Todd never asked you this
question I'm gonna kill him here on the
Rich Eisen show you're on the list of
notable films of your career Naked Gun
33 and a third the final insult yes sir
you were what did you do in that film do
you remember it well I think I do but go
forward what do you go the climactic
finale takes place at the Oscars yes
okay there's there's a exactly there's
an envelope bomb somebody's gonna
they're gonna announce an award and
that's the bomb and they're showing
clips of of nominated movies and they're
all parody movies
and I was the boy in geriatric Park so
it's the scene with the t-rex and the
shaking water and I'm the kid I'm Joe
Joe Mazzella from Jurassic Park and I
look out the window and it's a 45 foot
old man in a walker and he goes when he
clears his throat and I go and I had a
line but they cut it they cut it they
cut my line so then you never cross
paths with Leslie Nielsen I sure did did
so my my great uncle through marriage is
Robert Stack was Robert Stack was he
here
I won't you invited me yes Robert Stack
unsolved mysteries the original Eliot
Ness from The Untouchables also airplane
right there playing exactly it was
though he was he was he the guy that
bring in yeah consultant they brought
you anything
and he goes turd B if you see my friend
Leslie tell him I said hi and I was like
okay Uncle Bob and I go to the premiere
and it's in Westwood and Leslie sitting
at the back of the theater and people
are like lined up to greet him and I'm
like 11 or 12 and I'm pretty nervous
sure and like very timid and I step up
and he's like you know Leslie's like and
who's this and I go hey mr. and mr.
Nielsen I'm um I'm in this mood I'm in
this movie it's my first movie and
Robert Roberts tax my uncle and and he
told me come to come say hi Dee I'm
saying hi to you but I mean I'm here I'm
here because I'm supposed to be here in
the movie but I'm saying hi because my
uncle unless I do the whole thing was he
goes What did he say
I can't hear a word he say what did you
say repeat the whole thing again and I
do an abbreviated version my uncle's
Robert Stack him in this movie and he
goes Oh Robert stag great guy great guy
love Robert sack and to his credit after
the movie he came up to me and he goes
did you like the movie it was did you
have a good time and I said yeah
literally the next week this is
absolutely true I'm at home watching
Saved by the Bell or whatever and Leslie
Nielsen is in a commercial for a hearing
aid
so I'm from whatever reason that made me
feel better I was like okay it wasn't
totally my fault oh my god
Roberts dad what was Robert stacks
character's name in airplane I can't
keep all my they're in the car he's the
one who's trying to land the plane
wrecks you know and he was saying Ted
municipal bonds Ted never you know
always hold on to them Captain Rex
Kramer
that's right Captain Rex Kramer right I
loved the car the car ride there and the
background keeps changing it's just a
road and then it's like cowboys and
Indians chasing them and yeah let me
tell you since obviously your show is on
ABC single parents the the the six
police squads that ever existed was an
ABC show right way back in the day
that's what was this day still stand up
do they I haven't I haven't gone back I
remember my gosh wet like in my tweens
or whatever my parents were like you
should check this so this is what it's
from maybe it's just because of my sense
of humor it's really hokey yeah yeah my
favorite one just from that and then we
will get to single parents --is is Frank
Drebin
yeah is Lee Nielson he's undercover and
he plays the owner of a key store okay
okay and he goes and he's trying to
break up the local syndicate that's
shaking down all the street of the shop
owners and he goes into the the the mob
boss and he shocks him in his office and
the mob boss looks at him and he says
who are you and how did you get in here
he says I'm the locksmith and I'm the
locksmith great tell him stands up at
least come on man that's funny yeah oh
my god well that's now see now that's
like Mad Magazine funny where you go in
your mind you laugh but you don't laugh
out loud it's a first been a noun is
sort of the fun oh no you have to
explain that makes it funny tell me
about single parents teryn it is a
wonderful show that I have the privilege
of being on it's our second season it's
a show I get to watch with my kids which
I love and they're invested and
yeah we're about eight episodes in now
into the second season and our third
episode airs soon with Adam Brody who we
saw in the clip yes returning Leighton
Meester's characters baby daddy in the
show and in real life right and they're
sort of they're gonna may perhaps a
flame is rekindled perhaps not you must
tune in to find out okay
and Brad Garrett's on it - it's Brad
Garrett Camry Lewis
trough what's the word I'm looking for
like a cornucopia a cornucopia of
talented actors plethora by the way
that's that's three amigos I love you
rich yes that's three amigos exactly did
you say plenty goes yeah did you say
plethora from your little mouth a little
plethora have you never seen three
amigos yes nice movie Martin sure I can
do the dance so you have seen I've seen
it okay give me of like you know I'm
rich rich you know you're old another
police squad story oh my god okay well
every single episode of police squad
which starts with the music and it's
Frank Drebin driving around town yeah
and it would end with him crashing his
car into trash cans yes an episode one
was one trashcan episode 2 was 2 they
kept putting an extra trash can for
every episode until he ran into 6 that's
awesome that's my story on the open of
police squad it's great they don't make
shows like that they don't make them
anymore and I think we're on the same
page but I'm beginning to get a little
ornery about it
corral is the word I was Corral a Corral
of talented hopped very talented kid
actors single parents ABC 9:30 at Taran
Killam on Twitter at Tarzan nas marzan
nosy nosy someone stole my name before I
got my Instagram account going and when
people ask how I spell my name I say
it's like Tarzan nosy oh yeah and if you
text me my name will autocorrect too
no kidding no kidding I always say never
been more serious about anything I have
to spell my last name whenever I call
places all the time oh really yeah
oh my god the number of times it gets
butchered so I always say it's
eisenhower without the Hauer so that
would be my Instagram yes to do that I
think we should make him a ghost
Instagram for you is that right yes know
how er well just a way for you to creep
that's all and it's just police squad
stories it's just clips of police squad
and 1950s references yeah yeah and
police squad oh my gosh now we're
talking let me tell you about a star is
born in the original and this mug that
JJ Watt sent me with the Michigan final
school back it contains my tears we're
ribbon yeah we're revenues also I will
say like in your defense
we're also referencing the things you're
referencing simply we know what you're
talking about
Thank You terry gilliam any time come
back alright see you tomorrow excellent
fantastic we won't be but we'll just
leave that still coming taran killam
check out single parents Wednesday
nights at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Time
right on ABC for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune
- audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app